this house is a typical example of
modern Maltese architecture which
features clearly defined structures and
a smooth bright exterior the Edwards
live here northeast of a letter with
their daughter Isabel who lent her name
to the family home welcome to my house
from the front door you can see all the
way through to the garden and the
swimming pool this visual access makes
the outside area appear as part of the
living space
the Edwards moved into the house in 2016
Russel and Internet expert from Britain
and his wife Lorena have travelled
extensively and moved house 13 times
already here they finally feel at home
for the first time I like the natural
light I like it just flow flows really
nicely so I always feel at home there's
something lovely about waking up here
every day and pretty much the Sun is
going to be shining and that's really
nice because the Sun makes you happy in
order to bring the natural warmth inside
the owners relied completely on wood as
a design element the entrance area is
almost completely paneled with oak and
looks like a huge walk-in sculpture with
indirect lighting I was worried that
they will take a lot of my space because
they were talking as well behind of
these units you can storage things so we
have a furniture actually here so I
thought that it will take the space of
the entrance but like I said you know
you are witnesses this looks fantastic
[Music]
a white niche in the wooden wall in the
foyer is mirrored by a similar shape
shelf in the kitchen
[Music]
was trying to put the household together
because white is very Clinic very I
don't know minimalistic but for me need
to have a little bit of warmth so the
wood here was a fantastic idea and I
think that is different to any other
kitchen is designed for me I like it
like that
the architect wanted the solid dining
table to form a line with the kitchen
block but that proved to be impractical
you could walk around the entire length
of this thing then that's a long way so
what we tend to do is we tend to pull
this down a little bit and then we can
we can quickly skip through that bit
there which makes it a lot easier when
you're you know putting their food on
the table every day and stuff like that
so yeah Architects of great ideas that
sometimes you've changed a little things
here I know the staircase of the
multi-story building with 400 square
meters of living space is decorated with
a motif wallpaper that features
perplexing space perspectives
[Music]
the master bedroom on the first floor is
decorated in quiet beige and earth tones
in harmony with the wooden structures on
the ground floor
as is the color scheme in the living
room a built-in wardrobe is hidden
behind the dark blue wooden war living
room is the focal point of the house
normally we'd sort of turn the lights
down and and just relax why not they if
I don't say the only lounge that we have
really sat down and a giant drink
usually in other homes that we have
lived before never happened this is my
chilling point I like put my cushions
right and then like since we have like a
radio here I love to dance here the door
to the garden usually remains open in
the evening after all mild temperatures
prevail all year-round on the
Mediterranean island of Malta